bonsoir l'île afin que contient que
contient précisément ce projet de loi de
lutte contre le co2 kobe de 19 alors
face à cette crise sanitaire
exceptionnelle à edouard philippe a tenu
à présenter des mesures exceptionnelles
à la hauteur de l'enjeu alors le chef de
le premier ministre pardon a annoncé que
le cadre fixé par le président de la
république était très clair quoi qu'il
en coûte il faut soutenir nos
entreprises soutenir nos emplois et
aider lé plus vulnérable donc le but
c'est de dd de protéger la population
avant tout je propose d'écouter edouard
philippe au parlement de lui donner les
moyens de faire face à l'urgence
j'ai présenté au conseil des ministres
qui vient de s'achever trois projets de
loi touchant à projets novateurs
rectificative
[Musique]
hélas projet de loi organique très près
il vient compléter le projet de loi
d'urgence pour ces domaines relevant des
dispositions visent d'abord protéger les
populations
elle vise ensuite à prendre mesures
économiques et sociales exceptionnelles
requise par cette situation même église
en troisième lieu à vous donner les
capacités d'adapter nos règles de droit
de façon très provisoire pour tenir
compte de la situation très particulière
engendrés par les cabinets et qui vous
verse les relations économiques ou
administratives individuel ou collectif
lys d'enfants à tirer les conséquences
la possibilité d'organiser dans de
bonnes conditions le second tour des
élections municipales dimanche prochain
alors concernant le second tour des
élections municipales qui devait se
tenir ce dimanche alors le scrutin est
bel et bien reportées le un projet de
loi a été déposé cet après midi le
scrutin est reporté au mois de juin il
n'y a pas de date précise
et ce sera sous réserve bien sûr que
l'épidémie soit suffisamment contenu
d'ici là alors le ministre de l'économie
bruno le maire s'est également exprimée
il a décrit l'impact de la crise du
coronavirus sur l'économie comme un choc
violent massif et mondial
il a également présenté plusieurs
mesures écoutez nous estimons que ce
qu'il faut protéger par dessus tout
pendant cette crise économique ce sont
les compétences et des savoir faire des
salariés nous avons donc décidé de
déplafonner le chômage partiel pour un
coût total de plus de 8 milliards
d'euros sur les deux mois à venir
nous avons également fait en sorte que
les entreprises en particulier les plus
petites d'entre elles soit le mieux
protégé dans cette crise nous avons donc
proposé avec gérald darmanin le report
des charges sociales et le report des
charges fiscales pour les impôts directs
et si jamais des annulations sont
nécessaires à la sortie de cette crise
au cas par cas
nous regarderons si desalination de ces
charges sont nécessaires cela représente
un effort en trésorerie de 35 milliards
d'euros
nous avons mis également en place avec
les régions un fonds de solidarité pour
les entreprises de moins de 1 million
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires que ce
soit les micro entrepreneurs des très
petites entreprises des
auto-entrepreneurs tous ceux qui ne
pourraient pas bénéficier des autres
mesures de soutien vont bénéficier de ce
fonds de solidarité qui représente sur
un mois 1 milliard d'euros 2 milliards
donc s'il doit se prolonger sur deux
mois avec une participation des régions
de 250 millions d'euros
alors le premier ministre comme le
ministre de l'économie ont voulu montrer
qu'ils avaient conscience de la gravité
de la situation face à ce virus qui se
propage à grande vitesse rappelons le
déjà plus de 7000 cas dans l'hexagone
merci à lille afin amouzou et la france
qui compte même lit la fois puisqu'on
vient de l'apprendre 9130 cas de co vide
19 selon les derniers chiffes